abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
O
çok muazzam bir tesadüf bir iki yıl önce
çok sevdiğim Armağan Çağlayan'ın tedex
konuşmasını izliyordum YouTube'dan
anne o anda aklıma geçiyordum ki bir gün
kesinlikle ben de tek sahnesinde bir
konuşma yapacağım ama ne zaman
bilmiyorum üç sene sonra mı beslenme
sonra mı o
şu aradan üç ay geçmemişti ki telefon
çaldı ve ve tek de Ankara'dan arıyoruz
sizi
Adidas daire programında
o kendi ellerinizle restore ettiğiniz
tarihi evinizi anlatırken izledik Çok
etkilendik bu yılki domino
etkinliğimizde sahnemiz de görmek
istiyoruz ben çok şaşırdım tabii ama ne
daha çok vardı benim Dernekle ilgili bir
sürü yapacak olduğum işler onları
yapacaktım Hayallerimi gerçekleştirdim
Ondan sonra anlatacaksın Ben de hikayemi
o evde geçirdiğim bir çocukluk anıları
başlattım ve o yılları domino taşları
gibi Arda Dize Dize
yaşam mücadele mi anlattın o sahnede ve
şimdi bu sahnedeyim bu sahnede tüm
taşlarım verilmiş bir şekilde
karşınızdayım
bu huzurlusun
ormanın derinliklerinde küçük
yaratıkların yaşadığı gizli bir köy
vardı Onlar kendilerine Şirinevler'de
çok iyi geceler
etrafı dikkatle dinlerseniz kardeşinin
çocuklarının oluyorsunuz ve iyi bir
çocuk olursanız belki Şirinler'i bile
görebilirsiniz
Şirinler'in köyüne benzeyen memleketinde
Gargamel'in açtığı savaşların biri
bitmeden biri başlıyordu ve
bir de çocukken müptelası olduğum bu ve
kendimi sürekli
canavarlarla savaşmak zorunda bıraktığım
atari oyunlarına benziyordu Hayatım aynı
şekilde neşeli eğlenceli renkli ve bir o
kadar da zor parkurlar ve canavarlarla
kaplıydı
ve sürekli Can kaybetti diyorlardı bana
Ben çiçeklere bakıyor Can kazanıyordum
ağaçlara bakıyor Can kazanıyordum
yeşilliklere bakıyor Can kazanıyordum
denize bakıyor Can kazanıyordum ama bir
level atlayamıyorum Bu kez de
o de denizimizin Kültür balıkçılığı ile
kafes landmass iyiydi söz konusu ve
bu protesto gününe saatler kala
350 yıllık hatıralarla dolu tarihi
evimizde 10 yıldır içerisinde bulunduğum
tarih Evimizde ilk kez yangın çıkmıştı
Ya ben
hemen itfaiyeye haber verdi mi
ve elektrik panosundaki şarteli kapatıp
tipleri dışarıya çıkardım
telefonun kucağında eğlen netinin
bulunduğu laf topum ve Ayağında sadece
patiklerle dışarıya fırladı ve İnanılır
gibi değil Yine muazzam bir tesadüf
üzerinde o gün ilk kez giydim bu
eşofmanların vardı 150 yıllık Ata evimiz
ömrüm boyunca yaşatmak için neredeyse
anda içtiğim bu ataevi önce sarı oldu
sonra turuncu sonra kırmızı ve en
sonunda simsiyah olup karanlıklara
Gönül'ün Binbir emekle Yıllar yılı ard
arda dizliğin taşlar tesadüfle kendi
kendine mi yıkılmıştı yoksa biri mi
yıkmıştı bilmiyorum ama o an kına eminim
ki hedefinden şaşmamalı ydın
bu ve öyle yaptım O gece
ve
ailemin evine gittim
Ben
sabaha kadar bir yangınla yarım kalan
metnini tamamladım
yalnızca iki saatlik Uykudan uyandığımda
artık ayağa kalkamıyor kesinlikle
Yürüyemiyorum
süresi mutfağa gittim
biraz su içtim bir şeyler yuttum ve
biraz kendime geldim o anda sanki dövüş
filmiydi ben
o ağzı burnu Kan Dolu bir Van Damme
karakteri gibi yerden ayağa kalktım ama
bu sözlerimle bile saldırmak için değil
sadece artık vurmayın demek için oraya
gittim
abone ol
Bu da bizim
Ne
çabuk özellikle aratmayan benim tabi
tarifler
[Müzik]
Şahinler not fotoğraf
o örümcek Dağları ile
öyle batan
nerelerde edilmiştir
bu
Hey çamurlu bizim evimizdir
[Alkış]
Baba
tamam mı
mi
Evet devletimize yapıyorsunuz ya
[Müzik]
bu ama o gün anladım ki
Gözyaşlarım tokat gibi yan Clan mış ve
her Doğan
o kendi evi yanmış kendi memleketi
yanmış kendi yüreği yanlış casına renge
daldılar ve tezahüratlar yükseliyor bir
yandan Ama tabi Sultan sağırdı
gözlerimin önünde kafesler taşınıyordu
ufkumuza çamurundan vazgeçilmiş olsa da
hemen sınırdaki of ilçesine kurdular
kafesleri Tabii oradaki halk karşı
çıkmayınca da ben bir şey yapamadım ama
yapabileceğim günler gelene dek ve sanat
beni bugünlere kavuşturacak olan
yolumdur
[Müzik]
birbirine
görürse
Weber
bilmiyorum
seviyormusun Uşak
[Müzik]
abone olur musun gözlüme
gidiyormusun sevince
istiyor musun peki
olsun
[Müzik]
ahşap evin ve çiçeklerle dolu bahçem
küle döndüğünde o
Bu masalsı bir tepeden Yitik bir sahile
inmiştim
o
eski güzelliğinden Eser kalmayan
çamburnu Sahilleri kamburluk kıyıları
boylu boyunca taşlarla doldurulmuş Şerit
Şerit yollarla Duvarlarla
köprülerle ters ha nelerle kuşatılmıştı
ama yine de ailemin yanında olmak Huzur
vericidir sadece
içinde yaşayacak olduğu moda
bu iyileşebilir Mem için
çalışabilmek için yeterli değildir ve
ben
orada kendime yeni bir dünya yapmak
istedim binbir türlü Emek harcayarak
yeniden ve her türlü zorluğu işin
üstesinden geldim Ve sonunda prensesi
kurtardım ah
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
14'te
Bu
[Müzik]
araba
özel hayatımın içerisinde Zorlu
parkurlardan geçip level atlarken
çevrem için verdiği mücadelenin Daewoo
deliği karşısında motive olmuş olurum
içeride sağladığım huzur ve güvenli
ortam içeride sağladığım huzur ve düzeni
dışarıda sağlayabilmek için bana umut
verir yani içeride yaptıklarınla
dışarıda başarmak istediklerim için
hazırladığım Aslında ve bir de daha
İçerisi vardı ki odayı boyamak eşyaların
yeri değiştirmek şeklini değiştirmek ya
da saçlarını kestirmek yetmediğinde şu
kafamın içerisinde bir değişik yatmam
gerektiğini anlarım İşte tam Dünya Yeni
Bir yıla girdiğinde Ocak ayı boyunca
Gate 27 İstanbul'da misafir sanatçı
olarak ağlayacaksın ve hedefin
paramparça olmuş hastalanmış zihnini ve
ruhumu sanat aracılığıyla iyileştirecek
Team herşeyimle birlikte eserlerin
yanarken sanki resmetme yeteneğim ile
beraber renklerimi de kaybetmiştim ve
burada onları da bulacaktım geldiğimde
atölyede Çalışmak yerine bir arama odası
ve ameliyathaneye andıran banyoyu tercih
ettim orada kendime uygulayacağım tedavi
ile hem iyileşecek hem elimin küllerini
eserlere dönüştürüp ölümsüzleştirme
cektim yangından getirdim o asırlık
ağaçları ve onlardan söktüm çivileri
kullanarak zihnimi kağıtları akıttım ve
orada gördü 12 Trump var biri denizle
biri yangınla ilgili ve kağıtların
üzerinde birleştiler Ben de içinde
bulunduğu mekânın duvarlarını zihnin
farz ederek
şekillerden de
desenlerden
matematiksel Bir Düzen Kurdum orada ve
üretirken kullandığım araç ve gereçleri
içerisine dahil ettim çünkü bana göre
yaşamın her anı sanatla bir bütündür ve
sıradan görünen şeyler Harikalar
yaratabilir mesela ömürlerini içerisine
doğru oynarken siyahtan Kızıla Kahve ve
krem rengini döndüğünü gördüm yani yeni
paletin doğmuştu ve sivil çıkarken
parmağım denilmişti onu da kağıdın
üzerinde kan kırmızı olarak yeni
paletimi ekledim o da yazı defteri ile
kompozisyon kurmuştuk Gözümün değdiği
her yer uyum denge ve dinginlik
içerisindeydi ve bir de bak bu Dışarıda
Kar Yağıyor Bu kez ve Karanlıklar
beyazlara boyanıyor Ben de ruhuma
uyguladığım bu estetik operasyonun
başarısını kutlamak için dışarıya
çıkıyorum işte aynen bu şekilde oldu
Bütün bunlar
Bu nedir
[Müzik]
abone ol
abone ol abone ol
[Müzik]
abone ol
bu ara
[Müzik]
abone ol
o o
abone ol abone ol
[Müzik]
abone ol
ve
bu hikaye söyle devam edecek
kömürlerin içerisinden çıkardığım
ağaçlarla heykeller
ver renklerle ise resimler yapacağım bu
ve İsa'nın çilesini andıran çivileri de
taze dönüştürdüm Bir gün eğer sizi
yıkıma uğratan bilecek bir acıyla
karşılaşırsanız hatırlatmak istediğim
bir şey var
hatırlamanızı İstediğin bir şey var
[Alkış]
var
dolarlar fragman kendini
teşekkür ediyorum